accentue la pression dans le don-basse
depuis la contre-offensive lancée début
septembre plus de 6000 km² de territoire
ont été repris par les soldats en
quelques jours c'est le président
zellinski qui l'a annoncé ce succès
remotive les troupes mais dans le même
temps les séparatistes prorus vectoriser
un référendum d’annexion dans les
régions de donnéesk et louance qu'une
consultation qui devrait se tenir du 23
au 27 septembre prochain à vous Gulliver
Craig envoyé spécial de France 24
Gulliver que signifie cette annonce
comment faut-il la comprendre
alors d'abord il faut se souvenir que
d'après toutes les informations qu'on a
les soi-disant séparatistes de données
skate loin ce que nous font rien du tout
sans Laval du Kremlin alors il faut
interpréter cette décision soudaine
d'organiser des référendums comme une
stratégie une tactique employée par le
Kremlin peut-être pour que la Russie
puisse dire une fois accepté l'annexion
de ces territoires que maintenant c'est
son propriétaire qui est attaqué par les
forces de l'Ukraine et ainsi de menacer
d'autres formes de défense ou de essayer
de se justifier de se justifier de ces
actions militaires en disant qu'ils sont
dans une position de défense cela peut
être interprété comme un geste un peu
inquiétant si vous voulez mais il est
aussi remarquable qu'ils aient décidé
tout d'un coup d'organiser ces
référendums tellement rapidement le 23
septembre c'est dans trois jours il
vraiment impossible d'avoir une vraie
campagne et d'organiser un vrai
référendum alors la fausse était de ces
référendum semble être déjà déjà une
évidence et il semble que la décision
était vraiment prise sous la pression
puisque l'armée ukrainienne a commencé à
avancer et à même repris un village dans
la région de loin ce que ce qui fait que
la Russie ne contrôle plus la totalité
de la région de loin qui était jusqu'à
la reprise de ce village de Villereau
Olivia la seule région de l'Ukraine à
part la Crimée qui était entièrement
contre les par la Russie
comment est-ce qu'on réagit dans le
reste de l'Ukraine à Kiev notamment
le président velody merzelinski a dit
que c'était une indication que les
Russes et leurs
séparatistes leur marionnettes c'est le
mot qu'il a employé séparatiste était
vraiment dans un état de panique il y a
l'inquiétude quant à ce que cela
voudrait signifier quand aux actions de
la Russie mais la détermination reste la
même du côté ukrainien ils disent qu'ils
vont continuer à avancer continuer à
reprendre tous les territoires qui sont
actuellement sous contrôle des forces
russes